this giant rope creature perplexed us
all as he sort of dabbed us onto the
cliff before the fountain and palace
while it's mentioned in no item
descriptions we can actually make an
educated guess about what he represents
so let's tie a knot in it once and for
am so sorry about the pun a Shem an hour
or enclosing rope is a length of hemp or
rice straw that's commonly found woven
around torii gates shinto shrines and
also sacred landmarks they're here to
act as a sort of ward against evil
spirits or to indicate passage into a
pure sacred space quite a few of these
exist in game for example there's the
gate right before the valley that houses
the sacred serpent God and since the
divine dragon looks about 20 times as
divine as the serpent God I guess they
needed a bigger rope for the divine
realm blocking our way to said realm
however is the real corrupted monk
a warrior woman who guards the
Vermillion bridge so one thing that
marks female warriors as of the okami
clan is a vulnerability to savvy maru's
poison she doesn't have that
vulnerability but what she does have is
the signature laugh and movement of the
Okami
which marks her as a part of their clan
but perhaps she is not a part of their
bloodline anyway she has some really
fascinating additions to her character
compared to the rest of the Okami first
and foremost
she's infested hence she's immortal and
this happened to be a quality that The
Fountainhead thought would be quite
appropriate for an eternal watcher of
their palace her true name is priestess
Yao and this is a name that user
tsurumaru on reddit thinks is a
reference to yell bikuni a fisherman's
daughter who became immortal after
eating the flesh of anemia and I
completely agree with this theory so an
in yo is best translated to mermaid for
those of us in the West though more
accurately it's described as a fish
creature with shining scales a humanoid
face and the mouth of a monkey in the
story of yao bikuni she eats the flesh
of the ninyo and those who do so are
said to be blessed with incredible
longevity and this is what happens to ya
bikuni who in the story went on to
become a wandering immortal priestess so
there's clearly a parallel here two
priests sel the corrupted monk which
leads me to believe that priestess Yao
may have eaten a mortal ninyo flesh as
well because the divine dragon in fact
is called the Ning yo dragon in the
game's hidden files and related to the
divine dragon through a Chinese legend
are the great carp the great carp are
also a type of Ning yo there are fish
with human origins because the pot
Nobles all aspire to become a great cop
another part like mine did not any
question makes of you
he's the shape of our clan he's a
treasonous villain who attempted to kill
the Greek Cup for his own benefit thus
there have been many great carp over the
years and you can find their corpses
littering the fountainhead lake bed all
of these rotting corpses are sort of
testament to the ambition the
backstabbing and the desperation of the
pot Nobles to become eternal curiously
one such corpse is infested with a
luminescent centipede creatures which
may well explain the infestation of
Priestess yao if she did indeed eat the
ninos flesh like her namesake did so
this is a really strong theory to think
it could be this Japanese legend about
eating the flesh of the Nino which is
the missing puzzle piece to us
understanding where the infestation
comes from and at the very least it is
the fountainhead rejuvenating waters
that spread the infestation throughout
all of Hashanah as many of the infested
have clearly drank deeply of these
waters near the infested corpse of the
great carp is the Fallen spirit of
Yashida ku who haunts the bottom of the
lake so the headless are ruined forms of
our Sheena's heroes and Yashiro ku in
particular as a really interesting story
so he died to the palace Nobles but his
spirit fall states that he might not
have had his twin been at his side alas
his twin was lost in childbirth which
goes on to explain why we lose half our
health
when using his item and why a second
apparition fights beside him below the
lake
he was never quiet hole even
to death much of the architecture below
the lake has become uninhabitable thanks
to the overflow of divine water and
there's no one here capable of
rebuilding this because their
civilization is now literally comprised
of a warrior caste in the Okami
and a noble caste with the palace Nobles
and even more of their area is in the
process of being destroyed by the great
economy so locating the carp has become
a necessity
this explains our slug harvest
discussion in the last episode and all
of those slugs likely end up here in the
hands of the great Kaaba attendant my
father is now a noble and at the moment
he became one he found himself entranced
by a carp the great carp for a long long
time since he's done nothing but feed
that curse it carp young man please
release my father from the carps
bewitching powers I know my father
wouldn't wish for an eternity like that
so their father became a noble in the
lifetime of these two daughters so it
follows that these women might have been
some of the last to come through here
from member village they're the only
remaining humans we find in this place
and they're so old now that they've
basically become all but invisible to
the palace Nobles because they no longer
have any youth to drain young man please
be careful the palace Nobles have a
craving for the vitality of youth they
can't help themselves they want nothing
but to SAP away more and more of it for
generations wedding processions were led
from mibu village leading to the divine
realm which was an honor that was
bestowed only upon those who could
master the mibu technique of breathing
underwater
and when they arrived the wedding
procession was allegedly given water of
the palace which can then turn you into
a noble and then you would be fit to
become a citizen of the palace or were
you because behind locked doors in a
dark room that leads up to the
fountainhead peak there are these red
Nobles of the palace whose outfits
likely denote their higher rank and here
they feast upon the corpses of the okami
and they do so while right behind them
lie a set of white wedding palanquin
palanquins that surely belonged to the
wedding processions derived from a bow
village and if they had no problem
devouring their own kind
then they certainly wouldn't have a
problem draining the life force of those
coming from maybe village and if they
had no problem killing them then the
very least if their concerns would be
the great carp attendant who they
tricked into performing a really
undignified task you tricked him all
this time
nobility and eternity that pretty lies
to fool him give him back so as
Fountainhead culture descended down a
really dark path it's no surprise that
turn away and staccato so fit to leave
so these two are basically mirror images
of sekito and crudo the divine child and
their guardian just like us except that
time away and Takeru descended from The
Fountainhead and then began to mingle
with the Hashanah elites back then Lord
Ganesha hero and I would come here a lot
Lord Takeru would play the flute and
lady Tomo I would dance under the ever
blah
it was a wonderful sight notes that just
as Decatur played the flute of the
palace Nobles so too did Timon dance
like the Okami of The Fountainhead to go
little detail that day beneath the
branches of the ever blossom tree lady
tomboy tried to commit suicide why she
said those made immortal by the oath of
the dragon's heritage shackle their
masters so in order for the purification
to occur the oath bound of the Dragons
heritage must die yes precisely
speaking of the earthbound one trait of
those touched by the divine dragon
appears to be this streak of white atop
one scalp sekito has a Kudo has a kudo
2.0 has it he'll even be okami warrior
women have it but none have it more than
the purple Garbett lightning Bearer atop
the great sakura tree her hair is pure
white
perhaps a testament to the age of these
eternal beings that were blessed by the
divine dragon and it bears mentioning
that the actual name of the divine
dragon in Japanese is the Sakura dragon
which is a name that suits it way better
when you consider the nature of the
sakura tree these cherry blossoms if you
didn't know they only bloom for one week
in an entire year it's this period of
exquisite beauty that sadly cannot last
but is all the more beautiful for it to
the Japanese this symbolizes an
acceptance of destiny karma and
mortality and this balance is really
usurped and turned kind of a natural in
secular because the Sakura here bloom
permanently and this is of course thanks
to the Sukkot a dragon who drifted here
from the west and he probably was lost
until he discovered Japan which luckily
also had sakura trees and he decided to
settle in this fertile land which forced
the lesser gods out and I've spoken of
these lesser gods before since it's
possible that the last
the gods are the serpent God and Buddha
who were once a part of this region but
I should really also be mentioning the
white dragons of the tree
these wise and little dudes that also
fit the description their faces can be
found on the architecture of the palace
thus I think it's likely that they were
actually here before the dragon took
root they are of the tree after all and
I reckon these little gods were merged
with the divinity of the Sakura dragon
when he made their tree his own and we
mentioned the white hair of the oath
bound as well something that is also
seen with the old dragons they have
become this really sickly white
literally - because they are very sick
in contrast to the black dragons these
white dragons are a representation of
Dragon rots and the stagnation that's
afflicting us all and it's actually the
act of killing these white dragons that
purge is the affliction from the tree
which causes it to blossom which causes
the Sakura dragon to rouse itself back
to life and the first thing we notice
with the dragon is that it's terribly
wounded and there are some interesting
theories on this as well so first it
could be wounded because it's showing
the effects of dragon rot or maybe it
had these wounds before when it was cut
free from the West and drifted to Japan
or an even better theory it's possible
that these wounds the Dragon has mirror
the wounds that we secular and Kudo also
have sustained we are of the dragon's
blood after all and just like the dragon
has lost its left arm we have as well
and just like the dragon has a gash on
its chest Kudo also cut himself with the
mortal blade when he drew blood for The
Fountainhead fragrance another really
likely theory is that maybe it sustained
these wounds during an earlier fight and
the best candidate for a fight against
the divine dragon is turn away who
would have fought the dragon for its
dragons tears and term away may have
also been the original owner of the
second mortal blade the black blade it's
easy to complete sekito
without really realizing that the black
blade exists but it is a supremely
important item for explaining the story
it's real name is open gate a weapon
with the power to open a gate to the
underworld which if you didn't know is
what happens at the end of the game when
Ganesha arrow summons his grandfather
back in his prime to defeat you and it's
description has one final line one that
reads I beseech you make offerings for
the dragon's blood this links the weapon
to the divine dragon and while it's the
most sinister example of the divine
dragon
wanting an offering it's not the only
example of offerings the Okami dance as
an offering the mibu were brought here
as marital offerings those of The
Fountainhead had a practice of cutting
spirit emblems from their flesh with a
ceremonial knife and there's also a
shrine maiden here who was passed away
praying at the Dragons shrine and then
there's the black blade which was
allegedly used for offerings as well and
now let me explain why the black blade
would have belonged to term away first
we know the term oh I wanted to sever
immortality and for this she needed the
tears of the divine dragon
however while the black blade could
wound the divine dragon it couldn't
impart its tears and for this she would
need the red mortal blade which is
actually named the gracious gift of
Tears it's designed for this purpose but
unfortunately for her it was hidden away
by the simple high priest and no matter
what term away tried she could not get
him to reveal its whereabouts and she
did try to get it which puts her at odds
with the divine dragon second those term
away was closest to in a sheena ended up
knowing a lot about the black blade a
scroll describing it is less
outside of Asians quarters gain Ichiro
trained under term away and later
managed to find the black blade and
Takeda wrote of beheading with the
mortal blade and act that Ganesha doe
performs with the black blade at the end
of the game my point here is that Tomo
influenced the lives of so many people
and it's crazy to imagine that we might
not learn more about her in the future
this series took a long time to make so
if you enjoyed it please consider
checking out avati video comm where you
can find this ever-growing collection of
souls inspired merge designs our latest
piece is the fate of kings by John
Devlin available in red bronze or black
and white line art as a special
promotion if you enter code TS org 10 at
checkout you'll get 10% off but only if
you order in the next two days not many
of you are still listening at this point
in the video but I got to get something
off my chest this episode marks the end
of the five-part series and this
explains the majority of seculars story
this was a really low heavy episode I
know not everyone can stick through
these long heavy episodes but I'm
actually quite proud of this series
which is rare for me to say because I
feel like this series uncovered a lot of
law that has never been written about
online before and I think this series
will stand as a really good resource for
people looking to uncover the deeper
meaning that the game has and the game
does have a deeper meaning obviously you
know that but a lot of people don't know
that because unlike something like Dark
Souls people don't look for the deeper
meaning in sekito
because sekito already has a really
obvious surface level story but the
depth is there and it's good and I hope
you share it with some other people so
I'm happy that I could bring some of
that to light and up happy but there's
some of you who are still listening who
clearly appreciate that story too so
thank you for being a part of this and
I'll see you next time
[Music]